es ist seine bisher wichtigste Reise
Bundeskanzler Scholz macht sich auf den
Weg nach China die Erwartungen an ihnen
sind hoch wie wird der Staatschef Cheat
in pingen gegenüber auftreten welche
Balance zwischen Wirtschaftsbeziehungen
und Menschenrechten wird erfinden bisher
lässt Olaf Scholz sich nicht in die
Karten schauen und auch auf anderen
Feldern gibt er nicht gerade den
Teamplayer das Verhältnis zu Frankreich
ist mehr als angespannt und daheim in
der Ampelkoalition muss er in der
akw-frage auf den Tisch schauen einsamer
Entscheider der Regierungsstil des Olaf
Scholz unser Thema in der Phönix Runde
Phoenix Runde
guten Abend ich begrüße ganz herzlich
aus Berlin und darf in meine Gäste
vorstellen bei uns ist Jens
meyer-wellmann er ist Chefredakteur des
Hamburger Abendblattes und er kennt Olaf
Scholz natürlich gut aus seiner
Hamburger Zeit als Bürgermeister und ich
begrüße Gregor Peter Schmitz er ist
Vorsitzender der Chefredaktion des
Magazins der Stern auch in Hamburg
ansässig und herzlich willkommen
Alexander Magier Chefredakteur des
politischen Magazins Cicero herzlich
willkommen Prof Sabine Kropp
Politikwissenschaftlerin hier an der
Freien Universität in Berlin Herr
Schmitz was würden Sie sagen was ist der
Regierungsstil von Olaf Scholz wir haben
einsamer Entscheider mit einem
Fragezeichen versehen im Titel ist er
ein einsamer Entscheider es gab ja lange
dieses Bonbon über ihn oder dieser Satz
das Führung bestellt bekommt sie auch
insofern finde ich es etwas seltsam wenn
Leute sich jetzt beschweren dass er mal
führt weil zwischendurch ja auch immer
die These auftauchte wo ist eigentlich
Olaf Scholz und warum führt er nicht
mehr versucht es jetzt mehr es ein
bisschen mehr basta Kanzler wie sein
sozialdemokratischer Vorgänger Gerhard
Schröder er macht es eigentlich nicht
sonderlich geschickt also wir werden ja
sicherlich über einige der Baustellen
sprechen ist ja nicht nur die
China-Politik das ist auch die Haltung
in Europa in der Welt ehrlich gesagt in
New York Times war vor einigen Tagen ein
großer Artikel auf der Titelseite zur
Frage ob man Deutschland eigentlich noch
trauen kann ob man sich verlassen kann
auf Deutschland und das zeigt einfach
dass bei allen Schwierigkeiten die er
gerade und Krisen die er zu bewältigen
hat ist da manchmal ein
Fingerspitzengefühl fehlt weil auch wenn
man basta sagt kann man eine
Entscheidung oder einen Wumms verkündet
kann man eine Entscheidung ja vorher
abstimmen ankündigen und gerade das
gerade im Verhältnis zum Ausland
geschieht aus meiner Sicht zu wenig und
dass er basta in seiner Koalition als
letzter Gedanke sagen muss ist natürlich
eher ein Zeichen von Schwäche als eins
von Stärke auch gleich noch drauf Herr
Magier was würden Sie sagen ist Scholz
mit ja mit seinem ankündigen Wumms
doppelwumms sind das Zeichen von
Führungsstärke
gut die Sprachwahl ist ein bisschen
infantil die gefällt mir nicht aber es
ist eine Art von Populismus würde ich
mal sagen ansonsten glaube ich schon
dass er sehr sehr starke
Führungsqualitäten zeigt also
auch diese das Ausüben seiner
Richtlinienkompetenz war ja kein basta
sondern das war abgesprochen das war
vorher abgesprochen also er hat die
Grünen ihren ihren Parteitag machen
lassen und da dürften sich noch mal
Sonnen in ihrer in ihrem anti-agw Gefühl
und einen Tag später kommt Scholz und
sagt ist nicht die Laufzeitverlängerung
bis Mitte April
und das hatten die zu akzeptieren und
die haben es auch deswegen akzeptiert
weil sie es akzeptieren wollten also
Robert Habeck hat die Chance bekommen
noch mal sozusagen sich am Lagerfeuer zu
werden war dann aber doch sehr froh dass
letztlich der Kanzler Olaf Scholz ihm
den Rückweg bereitet hat und insofern
glaube ich der macht das sehr klug es
ist alles durchdacht
manches vielleicht nicht immer bis ganz
zum Schluss und manchmal ist das Wording
vielleicht auch auch nicht so ganz
perfekt aber im Wesentlichen ist das ein
sehr professionelles politikmanagement
das er betreibt
weil man ist das der Scholz den sie
kennen aus Hamburg professioneller
politikmanager also ja also eins ist mal
ganz klar bei Olaf Scholz und das war
auch in Hamburg schon so der platzt fast
vor Selbstvertrauen also ich kenne
keinen anderen Politiker der mehr von
sich selber hält und das auch so
transportiert wie er er hat schon 2001
als er in Hamburg Innensenator wurde
relativ massiv überraschend als erstes
im Rathaus in Hamburg gesagt in Senator
in Hamburg so hat Helmut Schmidt auch
mal angefangen
und er hat 2017 als er dann nach Berlin
ging uns Hamburger Journalisten erzählt
die Sozialdemokratie ist so in der Krise
das war sie auch in ganz Europa in
Deutschland auch und es gibt einen der
sie retten kann und retten wird und das
bin ich und so das ist natürlich so in
Hamburg sagen wir der Macht ganz dicke
Backen also aber er hat beides gemacht
also er ist wie Helmut Schmidt
Bundeskanzler geworden und er hat in der
Situation damals in dieser Rolle die SPD
aus einer ganz schweren Krise
herausgeführt okay Frau wenn er das wenn
man das hört dann hat man ja das Gefühl
Scholz hat einen lange Strategie sagt
das so nicht unbedingt sie würden sich
sehen
naja man sagt es im nach dass er lange
auf das Kanzleramt hingearbeitet habe ob
das dann funktioniert hängt natürlich
nicht nur von der Strategie ab sondern
auch von gelegenheitsstrukturen und auch
von dem Wähler Willen er hatte bei den
letzten Wahlen das Momentum hinter sich
hat das genutzt was den Regierungsstil
betrifft kann man vielleicht sagen auf
der einen Seite ist das
politikmanagement sicherlich
professionell es ist unter schwierigen
Bedingungen angetreten also ich denke
allein an die Koalition zwischen FDP und
Grünen die ja häufig rote Linien setzen
die keine Schnittmengen mehr ergeben und
auch die vielen Krisen auf der anderen
Seite kann man vielleicht kritisch doch
hinzufügen dass die Schwierigkeiten des
politikmanagements und auch der
Entscheidungen unter denen diese Politik
stattfindet mitunter eben doch
deutlicher erklärt werden müssen so dass
man die Bevölkerung die Wählerschaft in
diese schwierigen Zeiten mitnimmt denn
man wird nicht alle zufriedenstellen
können ich würde gerne kurz ergänzen sie
dem was Sie gesagt haben weil ich glaube
es ist ein sehr wichtiger Punkt das
Selbstvertrauen ist Olaf Scholz wir
haben darüber ja immer etwas gespot als
Journalisten man darf auch nicht
vergessen das ist ja ein Mann der ist
wirklich gegen alle Widerstände
geschafft hat ist ja zwischenzeitlich
noch nicht mal von seiner eigenen Partei
zum Vorsitzenden nominiert worden und
ich gehörte auch zu den Journalisten die
sich eher darüber amüsiert haben dass er
und sein ängstes Umfeld immer wieder
diesen diesen Masterplan entworfen haben
und deswegen sitzt natürlich jetzt
jemand im Kanzler am sitzen auch
Mitstreiter im Kanzleramt die sagen ja
wir haben es immer besser gewusst
unterlassen wir uns von einem bisschen
schlechten Umfragen nicht machen und das
nur kurz noch
aus diesem Triumph sozusagen seine
Stärke Ableitung und es ist schon
erstaunlich wenn man da länger zuhört
wenn man sein Umfeld länger zuhört wird
zum Beispiel die deutsche Energiepolitik
eigentlich nur als Fehler der Regierung
Merkel gekennzeichnet obwohl natürlich
die SPD und auch ein Vizekanzler dabei
waren und ich meine was er über Wladimir
Putin sagt ist schon erstaunlich wenn
man es sich anhört angeblich hat niemand
weltweit genau vorhergesehen was wie
entschlossen putin war außer Olaf Scholz
er ist schon immer gewusst hat dass er
das so vorbereiten würde also das zeugt
schon von einer gewissen
Selbstbewusstsein schussbüro die eher
sagen dazu gehört aber auch sie haben es
ja eben schon angedeutet er hat eben
auch riesige Nehmerqualitäten also ich
kenne umgekehrt auch keinen anderen
Politiker der so viele Niederlagen so
einfach weggesteckt hat also ich
erinnere mich an
2004 da war er gerade als
Generalsekretär zurückgetreten mehr oder
weniger zwangsweise weil Schröder auch
hingeschmissen hat und er muss zu gehen
und saßen saß er in Hamburg Altona
irgendwie hinten bei so einem Distrikts
bei der districtsversammlung der SPD auf
dem Schultisch mit einem Bier in der
Hand und liest die Beine baumeln und war
wirklich völlig fertig und man dachte
irgendwie dass die Zeit von Olaf Scholz
ist jetzt vorbei der galt als Scholz
humat und alle haben ihn verspottet sie
haben es eben gesagt dann wurde er
Bundesminister dann wurde er mit
absoluter Mehrheit Hamburger
Bürgermeister dann hat er trotz G20 was
ja in Hamburg ein echtes Debakel war ist
er Bundesminister geworden dann ist er
nicht SPD-Vorsitzender geworden und hat
auch das weggesteckt und ist
Bundeskanzlerin das ich kenne keinen
anderen der so viele
sagen so locker wegsteckt
deshalb halt eben auch so selbstbewusst
ist wahrscheinlich das hängt zusammen
wobei sie ja gesagt haben seine
Kommunikation müsste er verbessern ist
das so ein Punkt wo man jetzt nach fast
einem Jahr sagt er kommt da nicht
richtig an
er hat versucht nach ich denke an den
ukraine-krieg nach einiger Zeit die
Kritik an dem aufzugreifen und hat dann
die abwägungskunde die ihn bewogen haben
zum Beispiel bei Waffenlieferungen
zunächst einmal zurückhaltend zu sein in
einer Fernsehansprache dann auch
kundgetan mittlerweile sehen wir dass er
das häufiger versucht aber es kommt
manchmal sehr hölzern rüber nun ist das
eben auch ein Persönlichkeitsmerkmal
dass er voraussichtlich eben auch nicht
einfach abstellen kann ohne
unglaubwürdig zu wirken also er wird
wahrscheinlich so weiter verfahren und
vielleicht eben doch versuchen die
Kommunikation mehr sein Ministerinnen
Ministern zu überlassen die das ja
teilweise besser hinbekommen auch das
war ja Teil der Strategie hat ja in
Wahlkampf letztlich geführt als eine
Kopie von Angela mer uns damit auch
durchgekommen er hatte den wahlduellen
sicher auch immer extremer tv-duellen
immer extrem zurückgehalten also auch da
denkt er natürlich warum sollte ich mich
jetzt wahnsinnig ändern die Leute
schätzen das in gewisser Weise und es
kommt hinzu bei manchen Punkten wie
jetzt zum Beispiel der atomaren
Bedrohung ich glaube dass er da auch
nicht hingehen kann und alles teilen
kann was er vielleicht weiß also da wäre
es glaube ich manchmal besser klar
darzulegen okay was ist denn jetzt
wirklich genau das Bedrohungsszenario
das mich er zögern lässt im Kanzleramt
also da finde ich könnte die
Kommunikation manchmal besser sein sie
ist eigentlich zu ihrer Maßen sehr
tricky und jetzt wenn man jetzt schaut
also er sitzt ja jetzt im Flieger nach
China 22 Stunden Flug glaube ich hin und
dann elf Stunden ist er da wird er nicht
übernachten wegen Corona mit welcher
Botschaft muss er dahin reisen Herr
Magie also was mit weil das ist ja so
eine Sache wo es im Vorfeld jetzt viel
Kritik gab dass er jetzt fährt nach
dieser ganzen Diskussion um den
Hamburger Hafen also was erwarten sie da
jetzt also er hat seine Botschaft ja
dargelegt heute in einem sehr langen
Meinungsbeitrag für die FAZ der hätte
auch inhaltlich glaube ich dasselbe
ausgesagt wenn er etwas kürzer gefasst
gewesen wäre aber
[Musik]
die Aussage ist also einer der
Kernaussagen war China hat sich geändert
also muss ich unsere herrengehensweise
an China auch ändern wie genau das sein
soll hat er nicht gesagt aber
er hat auch so ein bisschen die Kritik
von Annalena baerbock wahrscheinlich
aufgenommen die sie ausgerechnet von
Usbekistan aus geäußert hat was nicht
ganz ohne Ironie ist
aber das Signal an China ist klar wir
bleiben Handelspartner wir können es uns
als Deutschland nicht leisten jetzt
inmitten einer der größten
Wirtschaftskrisen seit Bestehen der
Bundesrepublik auch noch ein
problematisches bis hin zu
feindliches Verhältnis zu China
aufzubauen das geht nicht und ich glaube
dass auch eines seiner Kernanliegen ist
China ein bisschen auf die Seite des
Westens zu ziehen was die
Russlandpolitik angeht da ist ja schon
eine merkliche Distanzierung eingetreten
bei der chinesischen Führung
lässt sich nicht mehr mit Putin
fotografieren auch wenn die beiden
Zusammentreffen also das wird er mit
Sicherheit versuchen doch in gewisser
Weise ein Keil zwischen zwischen Putin
und China zu treiben aber er hat
natürlich jetzt viel Kritik bekommen
also zum einen über den Zeitpunkt dann
hat er Kritik bekommen auch über den
Hamburger Hafen Lidl 6 Minister die sich
dagegen gestellt haben also wenn man wie
würden Sie das sehen da sein hat es mit
seinem Loyalität zu Hamburg zu tun dass
er da so so klar war oder was also diese
dieser Punkt um den es da geht da da
wurde ja immer so getan als würde der
Hamburger Hafen an die Chinesen verkauft
das ist natürlich muss man mal
differenzieren das ist natürlich Quatsch
also es gibt vier trainerterminals in
Hamburg der kleinste davon ist dieser
toller Ort um den es da geht und da
wollen die Chinesen wollten 35 und jetzt
wahrscheinlich 24,9 Prozent haben und es
ist auch nicht Grund und Boden des Hafen
sondern das ist das Unternehmen quasi
und es ist auch nicht unüblich dass sich
Räder mittlerweile an an den Terminals
beteiligen weil das weil das so eine
Win-Win-Situation ist die haben dann die
Terminals bekommen eine feste
Ladungsmenge und dafür haben die Räder
Sicherheit dass sie da auch end und B
Laden werden relativ schnell so dass das
passiert überall auf der Welt natürlich
ist das problematisch angesichts der
jetzigen Lage und ich verstehe auch die
Warnung und so aber jetzt sozusagen in
diesem Moment daran die gesamte
China-Politik aufzuhängen wäre völlig
falsch man muss auch die Dimension sich
mal überlegen in Hamburg ist jeder
dritte Container den wir verladen kommt
aus dem China Geschäft wenn wir jetzt
von heute auf morgen sagen würden mit
China machen wir gar nichts mehr dann
könnten wir den Laden da so zur Hälfte
dicht machen also Symbolik schon
schwierig fand es so zu platzieren in
der Zeit weil die Herausforderung ist ja
wieder ähnlich neben Russland gestellt
muss sein Geschäft war es ja
ehrlicherweise oder Energiegeschäft über
Jahre hinweg so dass auch die deutsche
Wirtschaft die Politik da sehr
hingedrängt hat dieses billige Gas zu
kaufen in China Geschäft ist es ganz
ähnlich da ist auch in der Wirtschaft
natürlich die Abneigung extrem groß sich
von dem lukrativen chinesischen Markt
zurückzuziehen und dann als Kanzler
wenige Tage vorher zu sagen ja guckt mal
hier machen wir doch wieder eine
Ausnahme es ist klein da haben sie
völlig recht wenn man es genau anschaut
aber es ist ja gerade die Symbolik diese
auch bei Unternehmen wie KUKA gab was
über wird übernommen und was wird nicht
übernommen und es war schon
bemerkenswert der Vorgang dass sich die
Außenministerin aus dem Ausland auch
noch melden in offenen Konflikt zu das
hat zum Beispiel Joschka Fischer
Protokoll und das hat ein Joschka
Fischer vor ein paar Tagen zum Interview
getroffen zum Beispiel nie gemacht
gegenüber Gerhard Schröder er hat zwar
seine eigenen Bereiche gesucht aber so
ein offenen Konflikt frühender Kondition
ist schon bemerkenswert und zeigt
einfach das Scholz da manchmal das
Gespür fürs mir nicht sicher das kann ja
auch ein Symbol gewesen sein an China
das kann man ja an China adressiert
gewesen sein nach dem Motto schaut her
wir sind weiterhin an wichtigen
Handelsbeziehungen interessiert und man
muss der Fairness teilweise schon auch
anmerken dass auch westliche
großrädereien zum Beispiel mal erst
Christ Dänemark durchaus auch an
chinesischen Häfen auch durchaus mit
mehr als 24,9% beteiligt sind und man
muss dazu sagen dass diese Diskussion
über die Beteiligung seit einem Jahr
anderthalb Jahren geführt wird das hat
keiner zur Kenntnis genommen also wir
haben im Abendblatt ich glaube ich habe
gestern noch mal guten juli
2021 darüber geschrieben hat sich kein
Mensch drüber aufgeregt aber die Zeit
ist natürlich jetzt noch eine Art
natürlich aber wenn man über Russland
nachdenkt und überhaupt über unsere
Beziehungen aber quasi angebahnt das ist
nichts was was jetzt plötzlich gekommen
ist und bärburg hat vielleicht diese
Botschaft eben auch in ihrer eigenen
Partei hineingetragen man muss auch dazu
sagen wenn man aus Kasachstan kommt man
hat dort mit Hilfe Russlands im Januar
noch eine ein Protest niedergeschlagen
also es sind dann doch eben manchmal so
versucht oder man müsste versuchen die
jeweiligen Dinge auch etwas in die
Balance zu bringen denke ich was stimmt
ist also insofern haben sie recht es ist
ein gewisses Unwohlsein im Kanzleramt
gegenüber zum Beispiel der
amerikanischen Position weil die
Amerikaner auf ein paar Tagen auf einer
Konferenz drüben da wird nur über China
natürlich gesprochen ja also da spielt
Russland eigentlich keine Rolle die
nächste Bedrohung ist eben schon China
und der Umgang damit in die Amerikaner
denken mehr oder weniger wir sind
unabhängig genug wir können uns dieses
die kapling Leisten die Deutschen
hingegen in gewisser Berechtigung sagen
wie sollen wir das überhaupt hinbekommen
und wie sollen wir so ein großes Volk
isolieren und ich glaube da ist ein
bisschen gerade die Sorge dass man in
diesem Konflikt zwischen USA und China
zerrieben wird trotzdem finde ich es als
Signal immer noch maximal unglücklich
wieder ist an der Stelle gemacht das ist
aber auch eine Illusion zu glauben die
Amerikaner würden jetzt ihre
Handelsbeziehung zu China einstellen das
ist einfach nicht der Fall also die ist
schon eine eine Divergenz zwischen
zwischen reden und tun weil sie schon
einiges ändern
sie hätten erwartet dass er das Geschäft
komplett stoppt also so wie es empfohlen
wurde von der Ministerien dass er das
Scholz sich sozusagen drei Tage vor
seiner China Reise hinscheinend sagt
Mama nicht ja warum nicht also es
Gegenteil im Gegenteil zu sagen es ist
ganz klein dann wieder zu sagen es war
aber wichtig als gehst du es guten
Willens zwischen das passt auch alles
nicht zusammen ja
noch ein Punkt der nicht ganz unwichtig
ist er hätte das Geschäft nicht stoppen
können also nach außen handelsgesetz ist
bei unter 25%
35%
das ist aber kein Kompromiss also die
24,9% gehen auch ohne Zustimmung der
Bundesregierung okay wenn Sie mehr
Informationen haben wollen über China
und unsere Beziehung zu Schiene dann
haben wir in der Mediathek übrigens noch
eine Phoenix Runde über China dazu weil
wir reden ja heute eher über den
Bundeskanzler und seinen Regierungsstil
aber da gibt es auf jeden Fall was
nachzugucken auch sehr aktuell noch über
China das nur mal als Hinweis weil wir
ja auch ja viele Dinge in der Mediathek
haben auch als Podcast zur Verfügung
stehen wenn wir jetzt noch mal auf den
auf seine ja seine Haltung das Schauen
noch mal die Frage mit welcher Botschaft
kann er sollte er da als auftreten und
wie wird er da wahrgenommen Frau Koffers
denken sie weil jetzt in allen
chinesischen Zeitungen ist natürlich
Bundeskanzler jetzt zu sehen
Deutschland gilt ja im Vergleich zu
anderen europäischen Staaten oder zu
Amerika auch nach wie vor als
pragmatischer Partner er geht dort mit
einer Wirtschaftsdelegation in die
Gespräche also selbst wenn man versucht
nicht weitere anbahnungen also
Großaufträge zu akquirieren wenn man
jetzt mal von biontech absieht dann ist
es doch denke ich eine Sondierung wie es
mit den Wirtschaftsbeziehungen
weitergeht was die covid-krise betrifft
was zum Beispiel die
Möglichkeiten für die deutschen Firmen
dort anbelangt weiter auf dem
chinesischen Markt zu bestehen wir lesen
zum Beispiel von parteizellen das sind
die Methoden die man auch aus der
Sowjetunion kennt um zum Beispiel
Unternehmen unter die Herrschaft der
kommunistischen Parteiführung zu stellen
also ich denke es ist auch eine
Sondierung die vor dem Hintergrund der
Tatsache stattfindet dass die
china-strategie der Bundesregierung ja
noch gar nicht festgelegt ist und sie
besteht aus meiner Meinung nach aus
unvereinbaren Zielen also eine Rivalität
und Partnerschaft passen eigentlich
nicht wirklich zusammen und es gab ein
Angebot von macron dass man gemeinsam
hinfährt das hat er nicht angenommen Mal
gebe ist denn das zu werten während wäre
das nicht ein stärkeres Zeichen gewesen
sondern gesagt man fährt da zusammen
ein stärkeres Zeichen für wen für Europa
ja kann sein weiß ich gar nicht ob die
sich darauf eingelassen hätten also im
Nachhinein kann man immer sagen werden
wir mal zu zweit hingefahren ich glaube
schon dass es auch nicht verkehrt ist
dass man als
Bundeskanzler so eine Reise allein
bestreitet
[Musik]
ich kann mir auch gar nicht vorstellen
dass es unbedingt in macrons Interesse
gewesen wäre wenn ihr in Begleitung des
Bundeskanzlers dahinfährt insofern ist
das vielleicht ein bisschen
ein bisschen Krokodil auch sehr einfach
also es gab ein bisschen
ja Sorgen darüber dass die
protokollarisch nicht auf einer Ebene
sind dass ich meine erste eben
Staatspräsident und Scholz nicht und
dass die Chinesen das vielleicht
ausspielen würden um sie gegeneinander
auszuspielen das machen sie aber
EU-Vertreter manchmal auch ganz gerne
also und meine wir kennen alle immer
noch er ist ein sehr sehr
selbstbewusster Präsident wie es Olaf
Scholz ist haben wir gerade hier noch
mal konstatiert also ich glaube es ist
besser dass sie getrennt worden ist aber
trotzdem kommen wir mal zu diesem
deutsch-französischen Verhältnis wo alle
sagen das ist im Moment auch unglaublich
schlecht es gab Verärgerung über
Ministerrat der abgesagt worden ist es
gab Verärgerung über ein Treffen ohne
Pressekonferenz also Frau wie würden Sie
es gerade einschätzen
es ist angespannter als früher es ist
offenbar auch die Chemie zwischen den
beiden Personen nicht so ganz stimmig
aber das deutsch-französische Verhältnis
hat in den letzten Jahrzehnten
eigentlich einiges ausgehalten und ich
gehe mal davon aus dass man das auch
wieder
begradigt bekommt vielleicht noch einen
Punkt ich denke auch wenn macron
mitgefahren wäre es ist ja nicht die
europäische Position sondern Europa ist
er mehr als Deutschland und Frankreich
und da gibt es durchaus sehr
unterschiedliche Interessen dass das
China Geschäft betrifft das ist ganz
erstaunlich eigentlich dass diese
Probleme in Frankreich jetzt da sind
sage ich mal nur aus dieser Hamburger
alten Hamburger Sicht weil Olaf Scholz
hat unter den länderministerpräsidenten
die Rolle gehabt die engen Beziehung zu
Frankreich zu halten und dann in Hamburg
immer kommuniziert dass ihnen das auch
extrem wichtig ist und Frankreich war
immer also wirklich ganz bedeutsam und
er hat viel darüber geredet und auch auf
da insofern erschließt sich mir das auch
nicht richtig vielleicht hat es auch
wirklich was mit persönlichen Verhältnis
zu tun es wird doch immer so getan als
ob das deutsch-französische Verhältnis
allein von der deutschen Position
Abhänge das ist aber nicht der Fall also
und schon auch zwei gleichberechtigte
Partner und ich weiß nicht ob
das Interesse auf französischer Seite so
groß ist dass jetzt irgendwie
das Verhältnis zu zu verbessern und ob
man auch bereit ist dafür die
entsprechenden Isolation auf dem Europa
gibt auf der EU-Gipfel also sind ja
schon irgendwie harte Worte und dann
weiß glaube ich einfach europäischer
Ebene wirklich besorgniserregender ist
und das meine ich am Anfang ein bisschen
mit der mangelnden Abstimmung ist eher
kleinere Staat in Osteuropa ja also die
sich wirklich teilweise vernachlässigt
fühlen also sie fühlten sich vorher
nicht gehört in den Jahren in denen sie
schon mehr vor Russland gewarnt haben
und Sie fühlen sich jetzt in den Prozess
auch zum Beispiel Energieversorgung wo
die Deutschen ja doch auch sehr nach
nach Germany first Maxime agiert haben
oder eben auch bei diesen Dingen wie dem
Wumms zu wenig oder im Doppelpunkt
zu wenig konsultiert deswegen glaube ich
nicht dass man sich so auf das
deutsch-französische stürzen soll so
wichtig ist weil das immer kompliziert
ehrlicherweise es war sicher schon mal
besser als im Moment ist deutlich besser
aber es hatte immer seine Höhen und
Tiefen ich glaube die Sorge in
Osteuropa davor das Europa wirklich sich
neu aufstellt und das vielleicht
Deutschland dass man diese ganz
mitbekommen hat die ist sehr wahrnehmbar
also wie sehr soll Deutschland sozusagen
das heißt es ja auf der anderen Seite
gibt es immer den Anspruch Deutschland
soll Führung übernehmen auf der anderen
Seite aber nicht über in Deutschland so
viele wird ist es auch schwierig also
wie schafft dann wie schafft Scholz da
diese Balance
ich glaube das macht er auf seine
scholzige Art also er geht nicht nach
vorne und und haut sich auf die Brust
sondern er macht das durch seine
sehr zurückhaltende durch seine sehr
zurückhaltende Art er weiß schon was er
auch für Karten in der Tasche hat das
ist ja ohnehin sein Ding also er spielt
die Karten nicht vorher aus er lässt die
anderen nicht nicht hinein gucken
aber ich gehe davon aus dass die Seite
sehr gut sind zwischen Berlin und Paris
aber Scholz ist keiner der
ersten ist natürlich ja es fehlt die
persönliche Basis das ist nicht wie
früher zwischen zwischen Helmut Kohl und
Francois das ist klar das wird
wahrscheinlich auch nicht mehr nicht
mehr kommen aber
das Scholz ein großes Interesse an einem
guten französisch-deutschen Verhältnis
hat das liegt auf der Hand und das im
Moment die Vibes nicht unbedingt
dahingehend
es darf ja auch nicht vergessen werden
also wir tun immer so als wären wir die
EU und wir würden alle nur unsere
gemeinsamen Interessen verfolgen das
stimmt ja nicht Frankreich macht eine
sehr jetzt könnte man abwertend sagen
chauvinistische Politik also das was
Frankreich als Europapolitik ausgibt ist
sehr oft eigentlich eine rein
französische Politik und das hat man
natürlich in Berlin auch gemerkt aber
das funktioniert umgekehrt genauso also
da muss man schon unterscheiden zwischen
den Sonntagsreden und der Tagespolitik
also eine eine Schwäche von Scholz ist
ja wie wir alle ein bisschen
Kommunikation und Kommunikation mit der
Öffentlichkeit also man unabhängig jetzt
von der Europa Thematik gewünscht man
sich ja in so einer Lage immer an
Kanzler der die Leute mitnimmt der ein
bisschen erklärt und der kommuniziert
und das kann er eben nicht das das weiße
auch und solche Sachen spielen ja
möglicherweise auch in der europäischen
Rolle dass man ein Teil der
Kommunikation läuft ja eben auch über
öffentliche Aussagen so und er kann also
das wird nicht da kurz widersprochen
er könnte es schon er will es nicht aber
warum nicht er möchte weil
wir leben nicht mehr vor 20 Jahren also
je klarer man sich äußert früher man
sich äußert je deutlicher man sich
positioniert desto angreifbarer macht
man sich und das ist eine Lektion die
hat schon sehr gut gelernt und daher
rührt seine ganze Zutaten höchst
unpopuläres ist ne also man darf nicht
vergessen wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel
das Anliegen der Ukraine ernst nimmt in
die Europäische Union rasch aufgenommen
zu werden
wäre das eine der größten Veränderungen
der Europäischen Union weißt du denn
riesiges Land im Vergleich zu anderen
Beitrittskandidaten dazu noch ein sehr
schwieriges Land was wir jetzt teilweise
vergessen in der
Euphorie und das muss alle sind sich ja
einig das vorher eine Reform der
europäischen Union stattfinden müsste
bevor man so einen Schritt geht nur wie
populär ist eine Reformdebatte in Europa
in Deutschland also ich glaube das weiß
er ganz genau und auch Angela Merkel
ehrlicherweise in der Endphase ihrer
Kanzlerschaft ist ja extrem davor
zurückgeschreckt auf macrons Initiativen
einzugehen das ist ja erst ganz am Ende
bei den corona-hilfen passiert aber
vorher war ja lange Schweigen
und er hat schwierige Partner ich denke
an Italien ich denke an Polen ich denke
an Ungarn also die Situation in Europa
ist nicht einfacher geworden er hat vor
allem auch schwierige Partner in seiner
eigenen Regierung auch dieses Jahr da
würde ich nämlich jetzt ganz gern mal
drauf kommen dass er wenn er denn sie
sagen er will es nicht oder er kann es
nicht kommunizieren je nachdem wie man
es bewertet was heißt das denn für die
ko als wir vor einem Jahr die
koalitionsverhandlung hatten hieß es
immer er moderiert so gut er hält sich
zurück und er moderiert so gut zwischen
grün und FDP tut er das heute noch
eigentlich
also ich jetzt jetzt nutzt da ja gerade
diese besondere Konstellation einer
Dreierkoalition aus es ist ja
öfter mal so dass dass der in der Mitte
der stärkste dann ganz gut da steht die
anderen streiten sich so ein bisschen
der habe und der Lindner die streiten
sich und dann entscheidet der Scholz so
ich glaube das stärkt ihn eher diese
Situation das ist jetzt keine
öffentliche Kommunikation sondern oder
sagen wir mal eine sehr sparsame er sagt
nur ich habe das hier entschieden und
dass meine Richtlinienkompetenz aber die
öffentliche Kommunikation mit den
Menschen die gibt es nicht und ich
glaube das ist ein Problem für die ganze
Koalition und auch die Art wie er mit
Journalisten umgeht da gab es ja auch
Beispiele wie auf Pressekonferenzen dann
so ganz knapp war oder irgendwie auf das
kennen wir aus Hamburg auch okay
erzählen sie mal ja also Scholz mein
Kollege und Chefredakteur Lars Haider
sagt immer wenn man Scholz nach dem
Wetter fragt antwortet er mit der
Uhrzeit also er antwortet einfach nicht
auf Fragen
das haben wir in Hamburg ganz oft erlebt
es gab landespressekonferenzen da haben
fünf sechs sieben acht Kollegen Fragen
stellt die einfach auf der handlagen zum
Beispiel als wir uns für die Olympischen
Spiele beworben haben in Hamburg und er
nicht klar sagen konnte ob die
Finanzierung mit Schäuble schon geregelt
war da hat er einfach auf die Fragen
nicht geantwortet und zwar quasi
stundenlang der da irgendwas anderes
erzählt und nachher noch gesagt
Journalisten sein immer so kritischen
Gründen alles immer so negativ sehen das
ist natürlich eine Art dies die geht so
nicht
in diesem cumex Fall agiert ja also das
ist ja fantastisch er hat ja gesagt also
da sind jetzt alle Fragen beantwortet
und ich sehe überhaupt nicht ein dass
mir noch Fragen gestellt werden alles
Schnee von gestern Sache beendet und
wenn wir jetzt noch Fragen stellt der
hat der hat irgendwie hat eigentlich gar
nicht kapiert worum es geht das ist halt
das ist halt seine Art der Kommunikation
nur kurz noch mal zur Frage wie er in
der Koalition moderiert also ich würde
sagen im Zweifel ist er eher Team
Lindner jetzt nicht aus Überzeugung aber
einfach weil Christian Lindner für ihn
halt sehr essentiell ist also das ist
der Partner den er braucht der ja auch
ehrlicherweise an manchen Stellen schon
deutliche Zugeständnisse gemacht hat
also im Zweifel hatte da immer
Anreiz glaube ich das ausgleichend zu
machen was völlig gescheitert ist das
muss man schon konstatieren ist dieser
Anspruch irgendwie anders in der
Koalition miteinander umzugehen also man
sich zum Beispiel anschaut was jetzt
gerade bei der Rede des
Bundespräsidenten passiert ist der man
Frankweiler Steinmeier sind sehr
beschädigter Bundespräsident aufgrund
seiner
russland-politik Vergangenheit aber
erkundigt eine große Rede an niemand ist
da von der Region meine Erklärung ist
dass sie einfach nicht miteinander reden
und wahrscheinlich nicht wussten dass
alle nicht kommen würden
dass sie mich gestern aber es zeigt dass
diese Regierung Moment nicht gut
abgestimmt ist und auf der anderen Seite
hat Steinmeier ja dann doch noch mal die
Reise nach China letztendlich indirekt
kritisiert er hat ja gesagt dass wir
müssen einseitige Abhängigkeiten
verringern wo immer das geht das geht
gerade auch gegen euch China das wirkt
ja fast wie so nach Karten danach treten
oder
dann müssen Sie ihn fragen ich weiß es
nicht
Frau Kopf wie würden Sie sagen also
schafft Scholz das was ist geblieben von
diesem anfangszauber sozusagen dieser
Dreierkoalition na dass ich der abnutzen
würde war glaube ich von Anfang an klar
denn die FDP und die Grünen sind ja auch
in allen Fragen die auf der
sozioökonomischen konfliktachse
angesiedelt sind sehr weit auseinander
also ein gesellschaftspolitischen Fragen
kommt man zusammen das ist relativ
einfach aber eben bei solchen Fragen hat
man doch häufig entgegengesetzte
Positionen und die FDP sind sofern auch
ein schwieriger Koalitionspartner als
sie glaube ich bei der ganzen
koordinierungsfrage die auch in die
Länder hineinreicht ja sehr wenige
Erfahrungen und sehr wenig Substanz aus
den Ländern mitbringt also sie sie ist
auf der Bundesebene Präsenz ist noch in
zwei landeskoalitionen vertreten auch
das ist eine Dimension der Koordinierung
und das Führungsstils bei der wir
beobachten können dass Merkel da
souveräner umgegangen ist also auch mit
den mit den Ministerpräsidenten
da gibt es doch einige Baustellen und
wie gesagt also die die jeweiligen
Personen und Positionen
zusammenzubringen das ist natürlich
schon sehr sehr schwierig
ist wie sie von Angela Merkel behandelt
wurden als Koalitionspartner das war
natürlich immer ein Argument dass man
das nie wieder sich antun lässt dass man
wie es damals Guido Westerwelle passiert
ist so schlecht behandelt worden dann
kommt das eben dazu dass man in der
Finanzpolitik so die letzten Bastionen
tatsächlich halten möchte also
Schuldenbremse das ist glaube ich für
die FDP essentiell und das gehört auch
zur Jobbeschreibung eines
Finanzministers das muss man auch dazu
sagen aber führt eben dazu dass man
jetzt unter den Bedingungen mehrfacher
Krisen eben auch ab und zu sich
aneinander abarbeitet und in der Mitte
der Kanzler mit eingeschränkter
Kommunikationsbereitschaft eben auch an
seine Grenzen stößt ist die Frage aber
wenn Sie alle sagen er ist so von sich
überzeugen zu überheblich ob das auf die
Dauer funktioniert also wie viel denken
sie dass diese Koalition unter Stil dass
das hält
also ich glaube dass der also sein
großes selbstbewusstseinnahme darüber
geredet aber ich glaube dass eine seiner
Fähigkeiten aber trotzdem auch ist im
Team letztlich doch zusammen zu arbeiten
sonst hätte er ja auch innerhalb der SPD
diesen Weg nicht machen können also er
muss er hat immer seine seine Verbindung
gehabt sein Netzwerk gehabt dass ihn ja
auch getragen hat insofern ist er jetzt
auch das ja ein hochintelligenter Mensch
der wird ja nicht sich die Grundlage
selber wegziehen unter den eigenen Füßen
also insofern glaube ich nicht dass das
ein Problem ist sein Umgang intern was
ist die Alternative
schmerzstunde sicher bereit ja aber es
ist keine ernsthafte Alternative und das
wissen ja auch alle Beteiligten in der
Koalition deswegen also das würde ich
optimal jetzt ein relativ langer
Zeitraum ist in dem keine wichtigen
Landtagswahlen anstehen eigentlich geht
es dann bis Bayern im Herbst nächsten
Jahres was für Markus Söder eine große
Herausforderung wird aber vielleicht
nicht für die Koalition also ich bin da
auch eher eher zurückhalten wenn es
darum geht sie fort abzuschreiben ich
würde die Koalition überhaupt nicht
aufschreiben im Gegenteil also so eine
Krise die schweißt ja auch zusammen das
ist in dem Fall eingetreten das Olaf
Scholz ich glaube Olaf Scholz nimmt die
Grünen nicht wirklich ernst
seinen Ansprechpartner ist eindeutig
Christian Lindner weil es einfach der
politische Profi ist also so Posa
letztlich wie wie Robert Habeck der sich
dann irgendwie so zu weinerlich vor die
Kamera setzt oder in in Talkshows echte
Ausfälle hat das nimmt jemand wie Olaf
Scholz nicht ernst
nimmt auf jeden Fall ernster als Robert
Habeck da bin ich von überzeugt und ich
bin auch nein ich bin nicht davon
überzeugt aber ich gehe davon aus und
ich würde darauf wetten dass Olaf Scholz
in drei Jahren auch wiedergewählt wird
als Bundeskanzler also der Charakter ist
echt widersprechen also das Olaf Scholz
Robert Habeck für einen Poser oder Baum
umarmen Prozent
dass ihre eigene Interpretation von Herr
harberg ist ich glaube nicht dass es
Olaf Scholz in der Situation weil habe
ist nein aber es kann ich glaube auch
aus Hamburger Zeiten kann ich sagen
irgendwie was dass er hat als die Grünen
dann 2015 mit in den Regierung kam in
Hamburg da hat er gesagt na wir haben
hier einen SPD Haus und so einen kleinen
grünen Anbau das ist also er nimmt
wirklich die Grünen teilweise nicht
richtig ernst also ich glaube nicht dass
er so von Herrn Harbeck denkt trotzdem
nicht okay wie ernst nimmt wie ernst
nimmt er seine eigene Partei inwieweit
ist er der sozialdemokratische Kanzler
Frau Kropp sieht man eher so ist das man
hat jetzt da ist Olaf Scholz der ist da
als Olaf Scholz und mit seiner Partei
die ist da auch noch irgendwie oder
zumindest geschafft diese zerstrittene
Partei hinter sich zu bringen im
Wahlkampf und auch ein Tandem das an der
Führungsspitze steht hinter sich zu
bringen sie sind loyal sie stützen ihn
er hat Kühnert als Generalsekretär
integriert und damit auch ein Stück weit
auf Linie gebracht die Partei muss
wahrscheinlich naja nicht ganz so wie
die CDU aber eben doch aufpassen dass
sie ihr eigenes Profil auch weiterhin
behält in dieser Koalition aber bisher
hatte das ganz gut hingekriegt und das
vor dem Hintergrund dass er von seiner
Partei ursprünglich nicht gewollt wurde
also
insofern weil die macht ihm sozusagen
Recht gibt weil klar ist deshalb fordern
die Partei sich da unter ja weil die
Macht dem Recht gibt das macht da eine
Punkt sein aber eben auch weil die
Partei weiß dass sozialdemokratische
Politik außerhalb der Regierung eben auf
ganzen stößt also wenn man tatsächlich
gestalten möchte dann muss man auch den
Kanzler unterstützen und in dieser
Situation ist die SPD auch in einer
teilweise ungeliebten Koalition mit der
FDP aber man weiß dass es im Augenblick
anders einfach nicht geht das wenn man
das so hört dann ist es ja hat man das
Gefühl er kann eigentlich da alles
durchsetzen die Grünen und die FDP
können nicht ohne in die SPD braucht ihn
und er kann eigentlich dann
Situationen die für ihn spielen also ich
meine das mit der Zeitenwende ist ja
jetzt keine Übertreibung also Teil der
Arbeit oder Transformationsarbeit
Übersprechen habe ich mir die anderen
Parteien abgenommen also nicht die Lage
nicht so dramatisch gewesen wäre und so
Herausforderungen so neu hätten die
Grünen manche den Kursänderung nicht
mitgemacht hätten die FDP manche
Kursänderung in der Zeit nicht
mitgemacht da musste er jetzt gar nicht
mehr so überzeugen es ist eben einfach
wirklich eine vielleicht nie da gewesene
Herausforderung und das da würde ich
Ihnen Recht geben Schweiß dann in
gewisser Weise zusammen dass alle sagen
wir müssen wir müssen das anpacken also
vielleicht musste er gar nicht immer so
überzeugen sondern die die Lage hat ein
bisschen diese Überzeugungsarbeit
gemacht in Hamburg hat eine Wesen gibt
es den Ausdruck OBD Olaf will das wurde
oft bestimmten vermerken geschrieben
wenn klar war da muss man gar nicht
diskutieren soll so sein ich habe es nie
gesehen irgendwo aber es richtet man
sich
ja nein
aber das wäre jetzt meine Frage was will
Olaf also wenn man jetzt auch mal die
nächsten fünf oder zehn Jahre haben Sie
das Gefühl man weiß klar wo da seine
Strategie ist naja er hat ja er hat
immer so big points in Hamburg war das
das Wohnungsbauprogramm das hat er im
Bund ja auch versucht also ganz viel
genau erzählt er dauernd war in Hamburg
sehr erfolgreich das war das wir waren
das erste die erste große Stadt die das
Thema wirklich so bearbeitet hat und das
hat auch tatsächlich dazu geführt dass
die Mieten zeitweise zumindest mal nicht
so stark gestiegen sind wie woanders und
solche Sachen sind ihm wichtig also das
ist im Bund sicherlich nicht anders das
ist eben um praktische Politik
für die einzelnen Menschen geht so es
ist jetzt natürlich eine Phrase aber das
ist tatsächlich was was er glaube ich
ernst meint und zwar realpolitisch
Sachen zu versprechen die man auch
umsetzen kann ich glaube aber ob er
wiedergewählt wird beim nächsten Mal das
hängt er davon ab ob wir wieder so eine
so eine krisenhafte Lage haben denn
manche Leute sagen der Scholz ist so
eine Art one tree Pony der kommt immer
dann an die Macht wenn die beiden
anderen als als unsereiös gelten das
hatten wir in Hamburg 2010 da war so
eine schwarz-grüne Koalition gescheitert
und dann kam er und ich bin der seriöse
Bundespolitiker und dann haben sie ihn
gewählt in der Bundestagswahl hatten wir
eine Lage da hatte Laschet irgendwie da
seine Aussetzer und Frau baerbock
angebliche Plagiate und dann kam er als
seriöser sogar und ob die Lage dann bei
der nächsten Bundestagswahl auch wieder
so ist dass er als der Garant für das
seriöse wahrgenommen wird das kann man
natürlich jetzt noch nicht so richtig
sagen
den Mittelpunkt Gestell hat dieses Meer
Respekt war jetzt nicht nur eine Frage
ich glaube dass sich das schon gewisser
Weise durch seine Karriere zieht eben
nur als arbeitsanw am Anfang und ich
glaube eine Sorge bei ihm ist dass er
das letztlich oder auch berechtigte
Sorge dass er es nicht wirklich einlösen
kann weil natürlich gerade das was jetzt
passiert Inflation
Krise und so weiter trifft natürlich
seine Klientel die er eigentlich den er
eigentlich helfen will am härtesten und
das kann er ja gar nicht ausgleichen das
kann kein Staat dieser Welt im Moment
ausgleichen sollte auch kein Staat
dieser Welt ausgleichen insofern weiß
ich nicht ob er sich sicher ist ob er da
eine erfolgreiche Kanzlerschaft am Ende
aus seiner eigenen Sicht hat ja und
Respekt ist ja kein Wahlziel das kann
man auf den Wahlplakat schreiben aber
das kann man ja nicht messen also
respekt das ist das ist eine Floskel so
das kann man politisch auch nicht
durchsetzen Respekt für Olaf Scholz ist
jetzt die ganz entscheidende Frage wie
führt er dieses Land die Industrienation
Deutschland durch diese Krise und daran
wird er sich messen lassen müssen und
daran wird er sich auch messen lassen
wollen davon bin ich überzeugt dass das
ein Anspruch auch er sagt gegenüber den
Bürgerinnen und Bürgern diesen Slogan
you never walk alone das ist sowas also
er will ja eigentlich vermitteln ich
kümmere mich er kriegt aber nicht hin
Frau Kropp da sind wir wieder bei der
Gründe in Deutschland glaube ich eines
der umfangreichsten Pakete zur Stützung
auf den Weg gebracht überhaupt das darf
man nicht vergessen ob das immer da
ankommt wo es ankommen soll ist die
zweite Frage also sagen
Verteilungsproblem aber
um noch mal auf die wiederfallschancen
zurückzukommen ich denke es hängt eben
auch davon ab ob man die Politiken die
unter dem Radar laufen also das heißt
Wohnungspolitik alles was mit sozialer
Sicherheit zu tun hat die Regulierung
Entbürokratisierung
Verfahrensbeschleunigung ob man das
alles auf die Reihe bekommt oder aber ob
man wie im Augenblick der Eindruck
vorherrscht nur hinter den Krisen
hinterherläuft und das in die Vorhand zu
kommen wieder und und Gestalter
bestätigt zu werden das ist glaube ich
eine der ganz wichtigen Punkte an denen
die Regierungen gemessen wird denn
einige Probleme sind ja auch aus der
Vergangenheit mit geerbt die schlagen
jetzt noch also umso stärker zu Buche
und dann muss dazu sagen ich meine die
Union hat beim letzten Mal eine Elfmeter
verschossen denn sie hatte wegen eines
unterirdisch schlechten Wahlkampfes hat
trotzdem nur knapp verloren
in der Union gibt der Friedrich Merz
klar macht dass er nicht der Richtige
Kanzlerkandidat ist und sie dafür einen
anderen finden ist das auch die
entscheidende
muss die Union für sich entscheiden ich
glaube nur und das Sagen zeigen ja auch
viele Umfragen das finde ich mehr als
nicht der richtige Kanzlerkandidat ist
ich glaube eigentlich weiß er das auch
wenn Sie die Frage lösen dann wird die
Union entscheiden wie stark aber ihre
These sitzt ja voraus dass die Union
eine Person in der Hinterhand hat die
Friedrich Merz übertrumpfen könnte oder
die die zumindest die Wählerschaft in
Deutschland mehr überzeugen könnte als
es Friedrich Merz jetzt als
Oppositionsführer tut ja also in der Tat
das musste irgendwie wunderbar für sich
herausfinden ich glaube nicht dass das
die Union nur für sich selbst
herausfinden muss das muss jemand sein
der nicht nur in der Union gut ankommt
sondern in der allgemeinen Bevölkerung
ja aber das ist ja genau die Schwäche
von Herrn
platziert ist ansonsten wird das nichts
werden für die Union aber Scholz ist auf
jeden Fall bei der SPD ja alternativlos
dann um das mal das ist ja dann
irgendwie auch klar wenn er jetzt so
[Gelächter]
welche Rolle wo sehen Sie wenn man jetzt
auf die Ukraine schaut wenn man nicht
weiß wie dieser Krieg sich entwickelt
und die ganze Diskussion über
Waffenlieferung war ja auch eine
Diskussion die in der SPD sehr schwierig
geführt wurde
kann er das Durchhalten dass er sagt
wir liefern teilweise aber dann doch
auch nicht alles also wie schafft er das
ja also
er schiebt es ja letztlich immer auf die
Amerikaner ab und tut ja so als ob die
Amerikaner bestimmte Schritte eben auch
nicht gehen in Wahrheit wünschen sich
die Amerikaner dort sehr deutlich mehr
das wird ja auch in Stellungnahmen sehr
sehr klar ich glaube dass irgendwann
also ich glaube dass diese ganze
Kommunikation keine so ein Beispiel
dafür ist dass eigentlich relativ viel
gemacht wird es aber ganz ganz schlecht
und zögerlich verkaufen würde ich der
Eindruck entsteht dass man nicht genug
will ich glaube auch persönlich übrigens
das in Deutschland wirklich nicht genug
tut in der Ukraine ist es mehr
unterstützen könnte es ist aber auch
noch dazu wirklich schlecht und stockend
kommuniziert aber liegt es daran dass
Scholz auch tatsächlich nicht davon
überzeugt ist oder dass er Angst hat
seine Grenzen ich glaube irgendwann
stößt es an Grenzen dass man der Ukraine
nicht zu 100 Prozent traut also ich
glaube das war aber man also
Waffenlieferungen offen zu kommunizieren
ist jetzt auch irgendwie ein bisschen
schwierig also ich glaube dass wir sind
in in der Lage wurden Atomkrieg an die
Wand gemalt wird von von Putin alle zwei
Tage und mit Waffenlieferungen sollte
man da irgendwie schon diplomatisch und
vorsichtig umgehen glaube ich glaube da
hat Scholz auch
die Bevölkerung hinter sich wenn ich die
letzten Umfragen immer mehr so angucke
dass die Leute nicht wollen dass wir da
ganz vorne
Mehrheit für
wasserfraktion an der
SPD-Fraktionsvorsitzende Rolf Mütze
nicht ist ein fundamentalpazifist das
ist doch klar das ist der Stolz da nicht
einfach
mich einfach so liefern bitte der aber
natürlich schon also ich meine trotz
Rolf Mütze nicht ist jetzt eine 100
Milliarden Programm den Weg gekommen
also ich meine ist jetzt nicht das
Scholz ihn gar nicht eingehe liefern
doch haben Sie das Gefühl dass wir viel
zu wenig liefern und was
an Waffen naja also liefern auf jeden
Fall deutlich weniger als zum Beispiel
die USA und wir sind also für unsere
Größe des Landes
unterstützen wir die Ukraine nicht
ausreichen ja die Frage wie man das
durchhält am Schluss noch die Frage
haben Sie den Eindruck dass er sich dass
er auf jemanden hört
ja auf seine Frau Britta ernst und auf
Wolfgang Schmidt den
Kanzleramtsminister der sein
langjähriger
Begleiterin in Potsdam
also auf die heute arbeitet
ich weiß es nicht aber ich nehme es an
ja ich glaube ehrlich gesagt das also
viele zu hören also ich meine ist schon
jemand der sich für Politik und auch
Details und so weiter sehr interessiert
insofern muss muss er ja oft auf
Fachleute hören ich glaube schon das
haben wir geklärt dass am Ende immer
denkt ich durchdringe alles am besten
was jetzt auch nicht immer das beste
Rezept ist aber ich glaube schon dass er
auf Leute hört er arbeitet sich auch ein
wirklich in die Teams ja nicht so dass
er aus dem Bauch entscheidet und einfach
meint er hätte recht also okay gehört
vor allem auch auf sein politischen
Instinkt und der ist nicht zu
unterschätzen
okay gut also ich habe eine Menge
gelernt über Olaf Scholz bedanke mich
für die Diskussion hier bei meiner
Monkey pro Kopf und Herr Schmitz und bei
Ihnen liebe Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer
fürs Interesse und jetzt geht's weiter
bei Phoenix mit Phoenix der Tag und
Thomas Bade bis dahin tschüss
[Musik]